>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: BOB COWELL IS A
RESIDENT OF MARIETTA,
CALIFORNIA WHERE AN UNKNOWN
NUMBER OF LEGAL MIGRANTS
RECENTLY WERE BROUGHT FOR
PROCESSING.
WHERE THEY NOW ARE IS OPEN
TO QUESTION.
HE JOINS US LIVE TONIGHT.
BOB, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
>> WE LOVE YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THANKS.
AND WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE
SOMEONE FROM CALIFORNIA
RIGHT ON THE FRONT LINES OF
ALL OF THIS GIVING US AN
ACCOUNT OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
SO PEOPLE BROUGHT TO YOUR
TOWN, WHERE ARE THEY WHAT DO
YOU KNOW?
>> THEY ARE FELONY IN FROM
EL PASO SUNDAY EVENING,
SUNDAY AFTERNOON.
AND BROUGHT UP BY BUS FROM
BROWNSVILLE AIRPORT IN SAN
DIEGO NEAR THE BORDER.
TO MURRIETA 60 MILES NORTH.
THAT'S MY TOWN.
AND FOR PROCESSING THERE.
THE PROCESSING TAKES 24, 48,
72 HOURS.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY.
BUT, THEY ARE THERE
WITHOUT -- WITH ONE TOILET
BASICALLY, THEY HAVE, I
UNDERSTAND, FROM THE SOURCES
THAT I HAVE THAT THERE IS
TUBERCULOSIS THERE, SCABIES
AND OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
RIGHT NOW IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THESE PEOPLE GO THROUGH
PROCESSING.
I'M SURE THEY ARE GREAT.
SOME OF THEM ARE GREAT
PEOPLE.
BUT THEN THEY GET, I
UNDERSTAND, A BUS VOUCHER
AND THEY GO DOWN TO THEIR --
I WAS TOLD THAT THEY ARE
TAKEN TO THE LOCAL MALL, ARE
A NEIGHBORING TOWN, AND THEY
CAN TAKE A BUS ANYWHERE.
WE SUGGEST THAT THEY GO TO A
SANCTUARY CITY LIKE LOS
ANGELES, LIKE CHER'S HOME OR
SAN FRANCISCO OR PORTLAND
AND NOT MURRIETA.
>> Tucker: CAN I STOP THREW?
>> YES, SIR.
>> Tucker: JUST FOR OUR
VIEWERS NOW GOOGLING YOUR
TOWN WHO AREN'T FROM
CALIFORNIA THEY ARE
DISCOVERING YOU NOWHERE NEAR
THE BORDER.
YOU ARE NOWHERE NEAR MEXICO.
>> NO, WE ARE NOT.
>> Tucker: WHY ARE PEOPLE
BEING FLOWN AND BUSSED TO
YOUR TOWN?
WHO THOUGHT OF THAT AND
WHAT'S THE POINT OF IT?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> YES.
WELL, THERE IS A BORDER
PATROL STATION IN MURRIETA.
SO THERE IS BORDER PATROL
AGENTS THERE AND WE THANK
THEM FOR THAT WE LOVE OUR
STATION THERE.
THAT STATION TAKES CARE OF
THE I-15 CORRIDOR.
THEY DO A LOT OF DRUG BEST
U. BUSTS ON THAT HIGHWAY.
AND A LOOKOUT OF THESE --
CATCH AT LOVE ILLEGAL ALIENS
ON THAT HIGHWAY.
SO, THEY ARE THERE FOR
ANOTHER PURPOSE.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY ABOUT
10 MILES NORTH OF THAT.
THEY HAD A BORDER CHECK
POINT EXACTLY ABOUT 60 MILES
OR 50 MILES NORTH OF THE
BORDER BY LAW.
I THINK THEY COULD HAVE THAT
WE DO HAVE THOSE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
BORDER STATION IS LEGALLY
THERE.
>> Tucker: IT'S JUST
INTERESTING THEY ARE BEING
FLOWN FROM TEXAS TO YOUR
HOME TOWN HAVE YOU OR ANYONE
ELSE IN THE TOWN BEEN
CONSULTED ON THIS?
HAS ANYONE ASKED YOUR
OPINION ON THIS.
>> NO.
ACTUALLY WE FOUND OUT THIS
BY INSIDE SOURCES THAT I
CAN'T DIVULGE BUT IT'S BEEN
CONFIRMED BY THE POLICE
CHIEF OF MURRIETA THAT THEY
ARE THERE.
I WAS CONFIRMED BY A BORDER
PATROL AGENT, SENIOR ONE
TODAY THAT I TALKED TO THAT,
YES, THEY ARE THERE.
SO WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE
THERE I HAVE BEEN TOLD THERE
IS 105 OF THEM THAT THIS IS
NOT NEW.
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN
COMING IN SINCE 2014 WHEN WE
HAD THOUSANDS OF
DEMONSTRATORS OUT IN THE
STREET IN THE TOWN.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW
ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: I DO.
I SUSPECT MAYBE MORE NEWS
FROM YOUR TOWN.